It's really interesting to see how my body might metabolize
drugs differently from someone else but what about all those
traits that aren't so simple, that don't just have one
way or another? The complex traits, like diabetes or heart disease?
>> Yeah, especially for many diseases, the genetics is complex so
we need to look at multiple SMBs to figure out what
your risk of disease is. So, well one example we can
go and take a look at your results for coronary heart disease.
>> Okay.
>> So Matt, let's go to your results, and then look under
[CROSSTALK]
health risks. That's where many of these
complex disease reports are, that involve multiple SNDs.
>> Okay, look so this is my health risk page. I am sure a
lot of people are interested in this, and it seems to list them in
order of elevated risk here first, and we have a list of them from
my risk down to the, average risk here. So, it looks like I have elevated
risk for psoriasis, Alzheimer's, chronic kidney disease multiple Sclerosis?
>> In many case, it might be slightly
higher than average, but not much higher than average.
>> Yeah, I see here that, for example, Multiple Sclerosis is 0.47%
>> Right.
>> But the average is like 0.34%.
>> Right, right. And especially when the average is low, you
can have a higher than average and it still can be low.
>> So let's scroll down to coronary heart disease.
>> Al right.
>> So it actually
says this is under my decrease risk category.
>> That means lower than average.
>> So my risk is 32.9%.
>> So let's click on the report to get the details
of where that estimate comes from. Okay, and let's scroll down and
it says, this is information for Matthew Cook, and it's under
the assumption that you have European ancestry, mostly, and, this if for
the rage, age range is between age 45 and 79. So basically what's getting
calculated here is your risk of coronary heart disease between the,
your ages when, between your ages of 45 and 79, so before
age 79, what is your chance of, of having coronary heart disease, and.
>> And it looks like the averages is 46.8.
>> The average is actually not that far from 50%
so men, and this is for men of European ancestry.
it's actually quite high for the average
man, the risk of coronary heart disease.
>> And it says here that I'm actually lower and they have this nice
sort of visual to represent that out of a population of 100 or more.
>> About a third.
>> Yeah.
>> You're, you're of with people with your genetics
your risk seems to be about one in three.
>> Mm-hm.
>> About 33%.
>> Now how is this risk determined? I
mean, if I scroll down can I actually see?
>> Keep
scrolling and we'll see some details. And we'll see.
>> Oh wow.
>> All these little bars each bar refers to a different SNV.
>> Oh, so each one of these represents
a different possible change in my DNA sequence.
>> That's right. That's right. And some of them give you protection, and those
are the green bars, and some increased your risk on those are the red bars.
>> Oh, wow. Oh, if I hover over it, it'll tell me.
>> Yes.
>> The gene and the, the SMD.
>> SMD, that's right. And your genotype.
>> So,
essentially, the number that you report for me is actually a combination of all.
>> That's right.
>> Of these together?
>> That's right, you know, if you multiply across all the different SMBs to
get you an overall average risk for people who have similar genetics to you.
>> We're going to focus a lot more on the idea of heritability.
>> Oh, yes.
>> And, on population variation, and complex traits.
>>
[CROSSTALK]
Oh, okay.
>> In lesson nine but, I'm just really curious if we
actually look at someone else who doesn't have a European background.
>> Right.
>> Let's look at Roy King, can we do him?
>> Yes we can, so Roy actually does have quite a bit of European ancestry.
>> Okay.
>> but this is still assuming, this is really focusing on
his European ancestry, and so his estimate, shows somewhat higher than average.
>> A
little less.
>> A little less than average.
>> but notice he is low in risk.
>> Right. And so, I'm actually curious to, let's, let's change
something else. We're going back to my coronary heart disease report.
>> Yes.
>> If I change the age range to let's say 45 to 54.
>> So that's basically saying in that
>> Age range.
>> Age range. What is your chance.
>> The average is 7.7.
>> Right.
Right.
>> So that's what we expect, people who
are younger have less a risk of heart disease.
>> Yes.Yes If you compare that to the top age range, which is...
>> 75 to 79...
>> 75 to 79. It's going to be quite a bit higher. because, a lot
of your, lot of your risk for heart disease is when you're older. So it's...
>> Oh wow, yeah.
>> It's quite a bit higher. So, yours is still lower than
average but it's, a lot of risk for any of these diseases
is weighted to late in life.
>> And just to be clear, this doesn't mean that I'm not going to have
coronary heart disease ever, this just means that
my risk for it is lower than average.
>> That's right. everyone has some risk but you can
see as you, when you compare the age range results that
it's still low now, especially in the next ten years, I
mean, you're still young, so your risk of having heart disease
in the next ten years is low. but by the time you
get into your late 70s it starts to go up a bit.
>> Okay.
>> Mm-hm.